sa sortie le film la pointe-courte eux
fut qualifié par georges sadoul
l'historien du cinéma d'un des premiers
films de la nouvelle vague est ce qu
avec le recul du temps vous êtes
d'accord avec ce jugement c'est à dire
la pointe-courte a été fait en 1954 et
la nouvelle vague avec la terre 58 donc
simplement dans les fêtes historiques
c'est un film précurseur j'étais
peut-être une des premières à dire qu'il
fallait tourner pas cher vite en toute
liberté d'expression essayer de casser
un petit peu le réalisme des films de
l'époque que je connaissais mal
d'ailleurs mais que je n'aimais pas bon
il doit selon le plan formel aussi sur
le plan du fond l'itinéraire qui vous
conduit de la pointe courte à black
panthers peut paraître assez long à ces
signaux je sais pas j'essaie de faire
des films comme je les sens au moment
gelé centre se trouve que les hasards de
mon existence de mes déplacements font
que de la pointe courte ici à hollywood
on peut penser que c'est un énorme
chemin mais géographiquement c'est vrai
mais autrement
j'ai toujours essayé un peu oui
un peu mais ça a changé pas tellement
commun presque tout le monde est là la
route où c'est moche
vous avez dit il ya quelques temps mon
grand regret que mes films sont enfermés
dans une sorte de ghetto intellectuel
alors que je suis sur le public le grand
public pourrait les aimer les apprécier
moi je suis sûr je me vante un peu
peut-être mais je crois que si on
montrait mes films comme un tas d'autres
fument considéré comme difficile à tous
les publics
il serait un peu surpris il serait
déboussolés ils seraient quelques fois
des variés comme on dit ici mais
peut-être qui les accepteraient comme
une partie du cinéma parce que même dans
ce qu'on appelle les films commerciaux
il ya des films que le public boude
complètement et les accepte parce que ça
leur est distribué alors à partir du
moment où il ya ça va une imposition
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on parle de
cinéma c'est ça que je vous explique
depuis un moment c'est déphasé c'est pas
le cinéma il ya des fois c'est juste le
fait d'avoir filmé les gens vivent dans
un cadre vivant c'est un rapport humain
c'est pas c'est pas une esthétique alors
je veux bien avoir fait une évolution
personnellement entre mes premiers films
et mai dernier vous comprenez pas ce que
je veux faire un cinéma qui forme de
cinéma mais il ya une partie du cinéma
qui échappe à toute esthétique à toute
discussion ils participent mais qui est
simplement
de garder dans une boîte c'est
exactement quand la photographie des
choses vraies des gens qui sont contents
de se retrouver seul immobiliers non non
non non non c'est pas si grave c'est le
cinéma souvenez
[Musique]